et dans cette vidéo vous dénonciez le
fait que le vaccin ait fuité d'un
laboratoire une année vous dénonciez
d'autres mensonges d'état mais vous ne
vous arrêtez pas là c'est une sorte de
panoplies un peu complotistes un
tout-en-un alors gérer le terme
complotisme jeune homme et j'assume je
mets moi c'est ya deux écoles moi je
l'assumé je sais c'est pour ça qu'on
c'est pour ça qu'on vous invité à
débattre que vous dites que dans cette
affaire il ya beaucoup trop d'argent en
jeu et c'est donc une affaire d'argent
que l'état a laissé entrer le virus
consciemment au début de la crise et que
le gouvernement alors ça c'est déjà un
peu plus répandue utilise le virus pour
faire appliquer des lois liberticides
alors quel point vous souhaitez
développer et quelques allusions vous
souhaitez je parle de lavernose invité
je parle je parle de ma vidéo juste en
deux ou trois mots parce que j'ai été
condamné j'ai fait appel donc ça c'est
un autre sujet vous avez par formation
envers l'institution
j'ai fait appel et j'ai eu une grosse
peine une très grosse peine 1 euro pour
l'institut pasteur 5000 euros d'amendé
avec sursis
non affichage au casier judiciaire et
800 euros pour la partie adverse et je
devais par la suite bien sûr mettre sur
mon facebook
comme quoi j'ai été condamné mais on en
parlera un peu plus tard si vous le
souhaitez moi je voulais m'adresser à
monsieur le député je suis très content
qu'il soit là parce qu'en fait il nous
fait encore une grande preuve et il est
très bon dans son domaine il nous fait
encore une place et moi finir vous allez
voir vous nous faites encore une grande
démonstration de ce qui se passe depuis
dix mois
ça veut dire qu'on ne sait rien vous ne
savez rien vous ne savez rien sur l'epo
pataude et je vais vous dire donc savait
rien sur les virus
on ne sait pas s'il va protéger on ne
sait pas si on va sûrement à transmettre
la maladie après vaccination et
attendait et le pire c'est qu'on vous a
posé une question oui mais vous êtes un
très bon politicien c'est pour ça que je
vous félicite vous avez été vaccinés ou
pas oui demain demain il avait répondu
demain d'accord ok et page
moi j'ai la grippe à delémont du soir 42
1600 membres d'accord moi je vais vous
dire simplement que c'est une mascarade
votre bonne vaccin c'est juste un
business et je vous le dis sincèrement
alors qu'ils aient eu les c moi finir
laissez moi finir je vous ai laissé vous
êtes exprimé toute la première partie
moi ça nous est mort ça va être rapide
moi je dis c'est une mascarade dans ma
vidéo du 18 mars au début vous quand je
dis vous et les médias on a eu un bon
goal 1 et une chauve-souris qu'on
fournit qu'escudé mois du terme
et ça nous a donné mais excusez moi non
c'est ce qui a été dit à la télé va donc
s'il vous plaît non mais c'est ce qui a
été dit à la télé je ne suis pas un
menteur
les relations sexuelles ça a été très
bernaudeau l'évolution l'évolution de la
vidéo on aura qu materner le jour même
où elle est sortie et on savait s'avère
qu'au bout de neuf ou dix mois ma vidéo
il ya énormément de choses vraies qui
sorte que ça soit sur madame buzyn c'est
d'accord que ça c'est là que c'est à
dire mais l'algérien de la clownerie qui
n'est tout ce qui s'est passé par
rapport à madany sy maintenant je noms
des noms à écouter monsieur aubin je
voulais pas faire de la politique ce
soit parce que je suis pas là pour ça
mais un monsieur macron il n'était pas
au courant depuis décembre que le virus
devait arriver c'est bien ce qu'a l'a
dit madame buzançais ses dires c'est pas
les miens et rien n'a été fait quand
j'ai dit qu'on a les héros très tonio
finir on est là pour parler du vaccin
mais bien qu'on fasse comprendre le
savait avant de parler du vaccin il faut
trouver la cause à effet est là qu est
ce que le virus a été créé par l'homme
oui ou non bah on a eu on a eu le
professeur pérol
les scores du pangolin s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
on a eu la vidéo du professeur peron qui
a été dénigré le professeur montagnier
professeur raout four tihan oui non
donc tous ces gens là donc dont un prix
nobel sont aujourd'hui des complotistes
comme moi c'est ce qu'on est en train de
me dire moi je suis juste en train de
vous dire qu'aujourd'hui le vaccin c'est
un business est ok vous le voyez bien
que c'est un business à août il n'a
jamais dit que l'état sait que la 5 et
par l'homme et on est dans tes raout
excusez moi il est parti avec la
chloroquine et d'un seul coup la
chloroquine mais vous êtes à combien
vous mélanger un peu tout pillay un tout
petit peu de vrais puis beaucoup de faux
bond concentrons nous sur le vaccin
le vaccin ça pourrait être un business
parce que c'est commercy series là sinon
attendez et ça peut être efficace en
même temps est-ce que pour vous c'est
seulement un business ça ne sert à rien
pour moi c'est seulement un business
d'expliquer pourquoi parce que le
bonhomme alors le directeur et moi même
mes enfants je veux pas qu'ils soient
vaccinés des gens n'est pas assez de
deux vaccins et oui c'est ça le piège ça
vous dérange pas qu'ils aiment mais
c'est ça le piège
jusqu'au mépris mais si vous voulez vu
mes enfants fait je ne voulais pas les
faire vacciner
vous avez essayé avec le gouvernement
l'époque madame busan en 2017
le 31 octobre a voulu mettre des amendes
aux parents qu'ils ne feraient pas
vacciner leurs enfants
lens est ce vrai est ce vrai non c'est
faux a pu alors que les taux
obligataires je peux pas vous les
renaissants il faut répondre alors tu
peux pas dire ça alors dans le savez
c'est de savoir ce que c'était le projet
c'est répondre je suis vice-président
des affaires sociales j'ai voté ce texte
là était simplement le fait de passer à
11 vaccins obligatoires que vous ne
puissiez pas aller à l'école si vous
n'aviez pas les vaccins obligatoires oui
pas une amende non au début il ya une
amende globale assez vous êtes très
introduit donc il n'y aurait pas
possibilité de mettre une amende aux
jeunes leur plaisait déjà l'affiché avec
vous monsieur je suis désolé j'ai
l'article a montré le moi je vais vous
le trouvez jeu l'article oui mais ça
veut dire que c'est vrai l'invention
bernard laporte eastgate a pris mais
n'est pas vrai si vraiment c'était une
histoire de gros sous
je vous dirai ce que vous pensez à un
moment ou un autre que on s'engagerait
là dedans alors que la pandémie nous
coûte plusieurs centaines de milliards
d'euros
est ce que vous pensez à un moment ou un
autre qu'on se pourrait se dire tiens on
va se lever le matin en fermant des
magasins ferment des choses comme ça ça
nous coûtait 300 milliards d'euros
c'est vachement intéressant c'est des
histoires de gros sous sol à nous
rapporter
vous imaginez sa vie mais oui j'imagine
très bien parce qu'un convoi suis rémois
s'est excusé moi je veux juste vous
expliquer ce qui s'est passé on a essayé
de mettre des amendes aux gens d'accord
ce n'était pas possible
donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on a pris
même et ne me dites pas ça c'était dans
tous les médias une amende serait mis
aux parents qu'ils ne feraient pas
vacciner leurs enfants
je ne suis pas un affabulateur new zik
ça j'avais une amende ou y'a pas moi en
avant
devrait pas y avoir une âme monde il y
en a pas alors le figaro je suis désolé
des morts